So yesterday, Donald Trump did his first press
briefing since the Republican National Convention,
the first press brief press briefing since
the shootings over the weekend.
It was insanely insane.
I don't know any other way to describe it.
It was a veritable historic house of horrors.
Let's just get right into the clips.
Now, as you know, one of Trump's supporters
shot and killed two people in Kenosha, Wisconsin.
And then we also had a Trump supporter shot
in Portland.
And Trump comes out and he says, I want to
give you an update about wing violence in
the United States.
Take a look.
A vaccine very rapidly in record time.
I also want to provide an update on the left
wing political violence that we're seeing
in Democrat run cities.
Under my administration, federal law enforcement
is working with state and local authorities
all over the country to comb through hours
of video, tracked down rioters, looters and
arsonists and bring them to justice.
We've just so before we go any further, I
know many of you know this.
Just give me 30 seconds to remind you most
politically based violence in the United States
is right wing.
Period.
The Anti Defamation League has studied this
for a long time.
Their latest report from 2018 says 50 of 50
people killed in 2018 were killed by right
wing political extremism.
78 percent were right.
White supremacists, 16 percent were anti-government
extremists.
Four percent were in cell extremists.
And one guy was an Islamist extremist.
Remember, I think Islamic extremism rightly
should be considered right wing because it
is really not.
I mean, listen, if you take religion to that
level and believe religion should be law and
that people should die over it.
That is not a left wing belief I've ever seen.
But that was one guy.
OK, so maybe it was 49 out of 50.
According to the ADL, CSI.
Yes.
Has identified that the overwhelming majority
of violence from extremists in the U.S. comes
from white supremacists, anti-government,
small government extremists, including militias
and so-called sovereign citizens groups.
The Center for Investigative Reporting looked
at this from 2008 to 2016.
They found that out of 100.
They found 115 right wing terror incidents,
63 Islamist inspired terror incidents and
19 leftwing incidents.
Overwhelming violence is from the right.
And then lastly, the National Consortium for
the Study of Terrorism maintains these profiles
in radicalization.
And they have found that radicalized individuals
since 1948 are 40 percent far right, 25 percent
Islamist, 17 percent far left and 18 single
issue folks who could be anywhere on the on
the political spectrum or outside of it.
So don't ever allow yourself to be distracted.
The vast majority of political violence is
right wing.
Donald Trump also claims without evidence.
That left wing protesters have killed a lot
of people in America, we will never surrender
to mob rule because if the mob rules, democracy
is indeed dead.
The reason we're continuing to see violence
in left wing cities today is that liberal
politicians, mayors, prosecutors and judges
are refusing to enforce the law and put the
rioters in jail.
These are rioters is a dangerous people.
These are killers.
They kill a lot of people.
Donald Trump given the opportunity to condemn
the pro Trump protesters that were shooting
paintballs at people, driving vehicles into
people, pepper spraying people over the weekend.
Donald Trump says while those were peaceful
protesters and he answers CNN reporter Caitlin
Collins by saying that her supporters, her
supporters, her supporters are the ones being
violent past the first.
You were just criticizing Joe Biden, saying
he didn't.
Didn't.
Laughter Antifa during his speech, you said
you wanted to talk about Left-Wing Political
Violence.
You did not mention that your supporters were
also in Portland this weekend firing paintball
guns at people some foreign tepper's.
So do you want to also take this chance to
condemn what Gore supporters did?
I understand they had large numbers of people
that were supporters, but that was a peaceful
protest.
And paint is not and paint as a defensive
mechanism.
Paint does not bullets your supporters, your
supporters, and they are your supporters,
indeed, shot a young gentleman who killed
him, not with paint, but with a bullet.
And I think it's disgraceful.
These people, they protested peacefully.
They went in very peacefully.
And I'll tell you what, they're protesting.
They're protesting when they turn on television
or read whatever they may be reading.
And they see a city like Chicago where 78
people were shot and 13 died.
For a city like New York, where the crime
rate has gone through the roof, or a city
like Portland, where the the entire city is
ablaze all the time.
And the mayor says we don't want to help from
the federal government.
When these people turn that on and they see
that, they say this is not our country.
This is not a country.
That was a peaceful protest.
Totally.
Caitlin Collins supporters.
What what does that even mean?
And Donald Trump received a follow up question.
He ended up defending Kyle Rittenhouse, the
17 year old supporter of his who has now been
charged with homicide after killing two people
in Kenosha, Wisconsin.
Take a look.
Arizona had five years, this one accused of
killing his niece and then the actions of
vigilantes like Kyle Rittenhouse.
We're looking at all of it.
That was an interesting situation.
You saw the same tape as I saw, and he was
trying to get away from them.
I guess it looks like he fell and then they
very violently attacked him.
And it was something that we're looking at
right now and it's under investigation.
But I guess he was in very big trouble.
He would have been he probably would have
been killed.
But it's under it's under investigation.
He's a private citizen.
Should be taking.
I'd like to see law enforcement take care
of everything.
I think everything should be taken care of
law enforcement.
But again, we have to give our cops back our
police, back their dignity, the respect.
They're very talented people.
And, of course, Donald Trump continuing to
insist that Joe Biden won't condemn violence.
Now, Joe Biden gave a speech yesterday where
he condemned all violence.
He actually said if it's from the right or
from the left, I condemn all violence.
It was it couldn't have been more direct and
simple.
And Donald Trump, who does not condemn all
violence, simply repeats.
Biden won't condemn it.
Take a look at what Donald Trump had to say.
Watch out for cars first.
You were just criticizing Joe Biden, saying
he didn't mean laughter antifa during his
speech.
You said you wanted to talk about leftwing
political violence.
You did not mention that your supporters were
also in Portland this weekend firing paintball
guns at people, some foreign tempers.
So do you want to also take this chance to
condemn what Gore supporters did?
Well, I understand they had large numbers
of people that were supporters, but that was
a peaceful protest.
And paint is not and paint as a defensive
mechanism.
Paint does not bullets your supporters, your
supporters, and they are your supporters,
indeed, shot a young gentleman who killed
him, not with paint, but with a bullet.
And I think it's disgraceful.
These people, they protested peacefully.
They went in very peacefully.
And I'll tell you what, they're protesting
the.
Protesting when they turn on television or
read whatever they may be reading and they
see.
Now, of course, Donald Trump here, he could
be right.
He might not be when he says that the tensions
and the unrest could increase voter enthusiasm.
We heard from Kellyanne Conway yesterday.
She said very clearly Trump believes the unrest
will help him.
Maybe it will.
Maybe it won't.
I think there is a case to be made that a
more systemic analysis like that done by election
predictor, Allan Lichtman, may be more accurate
from the standpoint of saying systemically,
how is the economy doing?
These major kind of qualitative factors are
more important in influencing the election.
It's not inconceivable that on the margins
in the two months between now and the election,
maybe unrest will activate more of the Donald
Trump base and get them to vote.
It won't necessarily change people's minds,
but it might activate certain parts of the
electorate.
I don't know.
Lastly, Donald Trump was asked not to go to
Kenosha, Wisconsin.
A reporter said, did you consider listening
to the requests of the governor and the mayor?
And Trump says that his person.
Are you giving any consideration?
Did you give any consideration to the governor
of Meir's request not to come to you?
No, because Kenosha was something we did a
good job when the governor didn't want us
there.
He didn't want the National Guard, as you
know, really was very reluctant.
But I give him credit because ultimately he
said yes.
And as soon as he said yes.
The problem ended.
But I have to see the people that did such
a good job for me and were meeting with numerous
people.
And we have tremendous support in the state
of Wisconsin.
So will this work?
That's what I want to hear from you about.
Will Trump trying to foment and then capitalize
on unrest, sort of playing arsonist and firefighter?
Is this a strategy that you believe on balance
in the net net net will be helpful for Trump
going into the election or not?
I want to hear from you.
We'll have continued coverage of this on our
Instagram page at
The David
Pakman Show.